i don't think it matters who i am
what really matters is the story i try
to remove myself from the equation by
going under the name mine and yours
it's me being inspired by our
experiences so in a way i'm i'm taking
what i feel is mine and then i'm giving
back
so it becomes yours
[Music]
so i've been here four years now i grew
up in london and after 28 years in
london i felt that i needed a change
what i wanted to do was to be involved
in the creation of a culture rather than
just become part of it and i felt that
dubai is the place that i could do that
i have arab roots so it was a place that
i could kind of integrate with
not feel too lost but feel that i could
contribute to something interesting
[Music]
when i started i wanted an identity i
wanted a way for people to recognize the
work what's funny about the cloud is it
wasn't a choice it was very much a
doodle and before i knew it people were
connecting with it and that's when i
started to analyze the entire idea of a
symbol and how you can use a symbol to
make people think
[Music]
dubai design district they asked me to
create something crazy and it was a
perfect opportunity i wanted to create
an immersive environment what was great
about painting the car park was that
it's in such an unlikely place you would
never expect it to be there i love
anything to do with the universe in
space i'm always lost in this wonder of
our position in the universe and who we
are
when i first proposed the idea to them
it seemed like it was
easily possible but very quickly into
the project we started to realize how
much trouble it actually was
and painting a ceiling just became more
and more
painful the further we went along
the project was 32 nights 50 000 stars
560 clouds 500 stencils and one trip to
a e
once you
just go a tiny bit beneath the surface
of what dubai is you find out that there
is this huge creative community here
and a great group of like-minded people
doing amazing things i guess before i
came here i had no idea that that even
existed
[Music]
you